the cover for fifty shades darker
features the Venetian mask that Ana
wears to the grays masquerade ball in
Chapter six you'd assume the masks are
thematically relevant to the rest of the
book like fifty shades darker is about
the masks we wear the idea of persona
and the exaggerated or false versions of
ourselves we create for different
environments and scenarios
congratulations you just put more
thought into metaphor than the author
[Music]
fifty shades darker is a 2017 film
directed by James Foley written by Neil
Leonard based off the 2011 novel of the
same name written by television
executive Erica Mitchell under the pen
name Yale James while the previous film
put a lot of effort into trying to
elevate the source material into a dark
romance drama fifty shades darker gets
trapped in the whirlpool of his source
material and drowns the key bit to
remember from the full history of Fifty
Shades is that darker was originally the
second half of a singular fanfiction
entitled master of the universe
encompassing chapters 53 through 87 of
that thick originally published online
in serial format from late 2009 through
early 2010 the other point to remember
is that even though creative leads had
contracts securing them for the entire
trilogy the second and third films
weren't technically greenlit when the
first film was in production in the
weeks leading up to the release of Fifty
Shades of Grey Universal announced their
plans for fifty shades darker in Fifty
Shades freed the two films would be shot
back-to-back in 2016 with darker
releasing early 2017 and freed in early
2018 then a month after the release of
Fifty Shades in March of 2015 it was
announced that director Sam
taylor-johnson and screenwriter Kelly
Marcel would not be returning for the
subsequent films both citing conflicts
with Mitchell as part of the reason for
their departure the two women would
subsequently be replaced by work for
hire director James fully best known for
a dozen episodes of house of cards the
1992 adaptation of Glengarry Glen Ross
and several Madonna music videos from
the 80s and television writer Neil
Leonard best known for being married to
Erika Mitchell like so many of the films
that I talked about here fifty shades
dark
is a movie that largely defies your
ability to keep it all in order
there isn't a strong plot or a clear
sense of escalation or even a coherent
sort of episodic series of events so
it's easy to get all just a bit jumbled
so for review the plot of fifty shades
darker goes like this oh and for comedy
purposes keep in mind that the following
events all happened in the span of 11
days for a prologue Christian has a bad
dream about his bad dark grim dark dark
sad childhood I'm not trying to make
light of abuse it's just that this
entire thread is handled with about as
much delicacy as the death of Batman's
parents anyway credits Anna is sad
because of break up the title montage
calls attention to Leela the woman that
is stalking Anna done in a way that is
filmic ly appropriate but comical once
you realize how little she will matter
to the film as a whole the other focal
point is Anna's new job as the assistant
to fiction editor Jack Hyde Anna goes to
her friend Jose's art exhibit which
consists mostly of giant copies of
Dakota Johnson's actor headshots
Christian looking distinctly purple
shows up and buys all the photos Anna
ditches Jose to instead have dinner with
Christian he tells her that he wants to
try again and this time you know what do
you call it a vanilla relationship I
mean we only do what you're comfortable
with well let's put a pin in that Anna
goes to work
Jack invites her out for drinks the head
of human resources makes a face that
tells the audience that this is a bad
idea because she clearly knows something
about Jack Hyde that's a red flag above
and beyond his name being Jack Hyde Anna
has an encounter with Leela in the
street where we are shown the bloody
bandages on her wrists letting us know
that she's a crazy person in a movie
Anna doesn't even touch her beer and
manages about three-quarters of a
sentence worth of conversation with Jack
before Christian shows up and they
immediately leave to get groceries and
product placement you
they cook dinner while Jamie Dornan
tries really really really hard to look
like he doesn't know how to use a
kitchen knife as Kristian and Anna are
talking she pieces together the
Christian is buying the company she
works for they argue they have sex they
pillow talk and Lila breaks in and
watches them sleep anna tries to give
back the $24,000 Kristian got from
selling Anna's old beat-up blue
Volkswagen and then Christian has one of
his people deposit the money directly
into her bank account Christian how do
you have my bank information they have
an argument about Lila over breakfast
Christian invites Anna to his parents
charity ball he takes her to Alana's
salon why would you take me to meet the
woman who seduced and abused you they
fight in the street about it because I
mean really
back at home Christian fills in the
backstory on Lila she wanted more I
didn't so I ended it when you and I were
in Georgia together she turned up here
and tried just to let it rest him for
them mrs. Jones my housekeeper put a pin
in that one too in the course of this
conversation he reveals he has a stalker
folder for all of his ex subs and
prospective subs Anna demands to see
hers and is rightfully upset sex is not
gonna fix this right now are you insane
Jenna but Christian placates her by
letting her draw a map of his no-go zone
with lipstick and the dossier is never
mentioned again they get ready for the
ball which includes Anna wearing a set
of Benoit balls also known as Kegel
balls they go to the charity ball where
Anna gets super turned on by the Kegel
balls and can I just say that I hate
this shot so much it's not strictly a
bad shot but I've seen it so many times
at this point that I can't help but
notice how overly posed and unnatural it
is with Christian being at a perfect 90
degree angle to Anna who's staring
straight at the camera and how it
doesn't actually flow with the preceding
shot because of the wave the eyeline
changes well maybe that's just me
during the auction anna spends the
$24,000 on a weekend at christians cabin
they have sex in Christian's childhood
bedroom a mysterious figure is lurking
on the stairs taking photos of
family it's important but it'll never
make sense
Elena confronts Anna in the hallway and
is just vaguely menacing do you think
you're the first woman he'd hoped would
save him we'll put a big pin in this
conversation because this is when we
start to really get into the whole BDSM
is damaged subtext rising to the level
of pure text when they get home after
the party Anna's cars destroyed
presumably by Lila put a pin in it and
then Christians spend the night and the
next day on his boat on Monday at work
jack is suddenly an [ __ ] there's a
whole tiff over Anna going to New York
with him for book Expo which turns into
a tiff with Christian about Book Expo
put a pin in it
Anna shows up at Christians place and
there's a lengthy introduction to mrs.
Jones put a pin in it Christian comes
home and the two of them bone there's
more of the weird non argument arguments
about book Expo where Christian is hung
up on Anna going to New York without him
put a second pin in it at the end of
work the next day Jack attacks Anna and
Christian sends Taylor in to beat up
jack
Christian gets Jack fired and convinces
Anna to move in the next day at work
keeping in mind that this is now the
middle of Anna's second week at the job
Anna is asked to fill in for Jack at an
editors meeting where all the olds are
like we should sell less books and she
was everyone with her wisdom by saying
actually I think we should sell more
books which earns her a temporary
promotion from assistant to Acting
fiction editor after eight days with the
company the fact that her boyfriend just
bought the company totally has nothing
to do with it I swear
there's a bunch of sex at work Anna is
talking with Jack's other assistant
Hannah who is now her assistant and we
get the movies philosophical statement
on the ideal nature of power I mean am I
expected to call you miss Steele I
expect you to call me Anna and I don't
expect you to fetch me coffee unless
you're getting some for yourself
and the rest of it we'll just make up as
we go after work Anna goes to her
apartment to get some things and Lila
confronts her with a gun
Christian walks in and uses his super
dumb hypno powers on Leigh Leigh Adana
runs away and wanders the street for a
couple hours
Lila will never be seen again and
there's still 40 minutes of the movie
left to cover when she gets home she has
a fight with Christian where Jamie
Dornan really struggles to keep his
American accent up with all the hard end
sounds she had a gun Anna and we get the
big moment you've all been waiting for
I'm a sadist I like to whip little brown
haired girls like you because you all
look like the crack [ __ ]
my birth mother I'm not a dominant I'm
not the right term is a sadist I get off
and punishing women women who look like
you mother
oh well that's disappointing put a pin
in it anyway he lets her touch his chest
which means he's fixed now and doesn't
need BDSM that night he proposes in his
sleep then again the next morning and
then Anna finds out it's Christians
birthday on Saturday so she gets him a
gift and now he needs to go to Portland
for work but he'll be back Friday night
so Anna goes drinking with friends and
Christians helicopter crashes but it's
cool he's fine he walks in no big deal
what the hell they all do and it tells
him to open the gift because it's past
midnight so it's his birthday and it's a
keychain that says yes so they have a
bunch of sex at Christian's birthday
party there was a waiter with hors
d'oeuvres who gets all moon eyed at
Christian put a pin in it then Christian
announces their engagement which elicits
a sinister close-up from Jose who is
inexplicably at this party even though
in the extended edition he explicitly
says he's not going to be there because
it would be weird will we be seeing
tomorrow at his party
there's another confrontation with Elena
that includes a baffling jump cut
that right there I didn't cut that it
really just straight-up cuts between two
nearly identical close-ups that are only
offset by a slight angle this movie was
in theaters back in Christian's
childhood room Anna and Christian have a
conversation about Christians birth mom
and there's a Chronicles of Riddick
poster on the wall behind his door which
has a background storytelling element is
far more interesting than anything in
the actual conversation then they go out
to the boathouse Christian RiRi proposes
this time with a ring and there's
fireworks and everyone is happy except
Jack Hyde who's looking on from the
other side of the lake being all
sinister and he's got a printout of the
photo that he took of the photo in the
house so now that we know that the
sinister person during the ball was in
fact Jack Hyde anyway that's what
happens in this movie are you tired of
subscription loot boxes that send you
metaphorical garbage every month
introduced in gar box
the only subscription loot box focused
exclusively on literal actual garbage
the theme this month and every month is
fast food paper waste go to D rip slash
foldable human and enter the offer code
send me garbage to start receiving gar
box today
most of the nice things that there are
to say about the movie are largely
carried over from the previous film to
the point that I could pretty much
copy-paste those details here the
removal of Anna's internal monologue
both improves the story and her
character Christian is still a
manipulative stalker but he's less of a
terrifying rage monster the through line
where a Christian endlessly needles Anna
over her eating habits has been dropped
entirely and ditto the endless needling
over birth control so on so forth for
book specific changes it suggested that
Anna gets her temporary promotion from
assistant to fiction editor in the
middle of her second week at the job
because she impresses the weirdo
editor-in-chief which I mean it's an
improvement over the book where
Christian pretty blatantly pull strings
to make sure she gets promoted and then
mocks her for it
don't tell them he says don't tell them
what that I own it the heads of
agreement was signed yesterday the news
is embargoed for four weeks while the
management at si P makes some changes oh
well I be out of a job
I asked alarmed I sincerely doubt it
Christian says Reilly trying to stifle
his smile the management here gave you
hi its job to babysit they didn't want
the expense of hiring a senior executive
when the company was made to sail they
had no idea what the new owner would do
with it once it passed into his
ownership and wisely they didn't want an
expensive redundancy so they gave you hi
its job to care take until the new owner
he pauses and his lips twitch in an
ironic smile namely me took over a lot
of boring logistical stuff is being
dropped the movie takes advantage of the
break between films to conveniently
forget that half of Ana's life is in
Portland and half is in Seattle so we
don't need to deal with her trying to
get down to Portland for Jose's show or
Jose being stranded in Seattle during
Christians helicopter mishap forcing him
to sleep in the bedroom
Christian keeps for his subs listening
to the two of them bang in the room
above all night yes literally all of
that is in the book in excruciating
detail he switches the water on to Mac's
cheese arctic water spurts over my
backside and I squeal then stop mindful
once more that Jose is
above us the break between the movies
also implies less concrete span of time
between the two films there's still
definitely the impression that it's
recent and based on events that have
stated temporal relationships like
Jose's exhibit the overall timeline
hasn't really been changed at all but
it's better to not call attention to it
because it kind of sucks all the drama
and significance out of the end of the
previous movie once you say it out loud
that the two of them remain broken up
for less than four full days still
saying that the movie has at least
managed to rise above the source
material is in this case damning with
faint praise the filmmakers don't
exactly deserve Oscars for having the
good sense to drop the scene where Anna
is blown away that Christian has given
her an iPod with 12 songs on it this
book takes place in 2011 from the
perspective of design tone and the
overall nature of the adaptation darker
is still decidedly contiguous with the
first film and this is probably the most
interesting thing about it despite the
change in creative leads and Erica
Mitchell consolidating creative power
the second and third film are still
built on the foundation laid by the
previous writer and director most
notably Anna and Christian still behave
like their film versions instead of
their book versions now I can't speak
definitively as to why but I have an
educated guess and it comes down to
studio interference and the nature of
the new hires the first film had
performed incredibly well at the box
office but there's still the limited
shelf life for these kinds of cultural
phenomenon and even by 2015 it was
obvious that Fifty Shades moment of
cultural relevance had peaked and was
now on the downslope this is why
Universal opted to film the two movies
back-to-back on a reduced budget per
film James Foley's hiring wasn't
official until November 2015 with the
film's scheduled to go to camera in
February of 2016 with such an extremely
limited time frame and an already
successful film there was probably a
mandate from Universal that boiled down
to no more big changes the other thing
that significant is that Neil Leonard
and James Foley both have the majority
of their experience work
in television in fact this is probably
why James Foley was hired in the first
place as a television director he's used
to coming into a situation with limited
personal pre-production where he's
directing episodes 6 8 and 13 of a
series that's been running for two
seasons already where production
designers and the camera department
essentially work independent of him you
know he shows up on set and costume
department comes to him is like okay
here's the stuff that this character
wears which one do you want for this
scene television directors and writers
tend to put a lot of power into the
hands of actors because the actors are
the constant in the scenario so with a
probable mandate from universal to just
get things done stay on schedule and not
rock the boat I would assume that Foley
in turn would basically defer to Dakota
Johnson and Jamie Dornan on set whenever
it came to questions about how their
characters would behave their phrasing
tone of voice reactions and general
interplay that said you can still
totally tell that Sam taylor-johnson and
Kelly Marcel were replaced by men
there's a character to the framing and
blocking of scenes most notable in the
sex out of darker sex scenes Christian
only takes off his pants once and
there's a distinct discomfort with
framing Christians nudity in an overtly
sexual manner meant for consumption
Landing instead on self depictions of
masculinity that hetero men are more
comfortable with where the first film
included shots like this where the focus
of the shot is on Christians sexual form
his movement and poise in an overtly
sexual scenario the closest equivalent
shot in darker is when Anna watches
Christian work out it may feel slight
the difference between a shot that says
this man is coming to [ __ ] you and one
that says look at this dude getting buff
but it's an aesthetic sensibility that
pervades the visual language of the film
so let's start talking about that
adaptation fifty shades darker is a
nightmare of a book to try and adapt as
the second half of a huge directionless
serial fan fiction it more than
any other part of the series suffers
from all the maladies that serial
fiction tends to attract the overall
plot is unfocused and spread sparsely
throughout the book the vast majority of
the page count is dedicated to
repetitive arguments and squabbles that
neither advance the plot or develop the
characters and the nearest thing to a
central plot resolves a little more than
halfway through the book with the
remainder of the volume stuffed to
bursting with more arguments in a series
of dead-end episodes that are telltale
of a zombie fik one that is narrative ly
resolved but continues to update weekly
propelled only by the author's own
creative inertia and ego the movie
adapts maybe 50% of the book and huge
chunks of the first half are just
outright discarded like to give you an
idea of what was dropped after Anna's
car is trashed they spend several hours
lingering at a Scala well phone calls
are made there's an argument about Lila
and an argument about Elena
before they move to a hotel a process
that includes a beat by beat navigation
of who is staying in which room as
though it's going to be critically
important for the reader to have a sense
of the geography of the hotel and how
far away their bodyguards are but then
nothing happens all they do is have sex
sleep and Christians on call
gynaecologist comes over to the hotel
and guilt trips Anna for forgetting to
take her pill and then gives her a
pregnancy test and hormone injection
then they buy Anna a new car which
Christian refuses to let her drive oh
and also earlier she found out that
Christian buys all his subs of the same
car and so this is important because
Christian is now buying her a car that's
different from the car that all be the
other subs got and I know it feels like
I'm spending a lot of time belaboring
this point and now imagine just how
thrilling it must be to actually read
this because it gets a lot of pages the
longest chapter in the book is an
extension of the argument about New York
that involves Anna getting an email from
Elena and then sending an angry email to
Christian to which Christian gets upset
because she sent us an explicit email
over the company's servers so off page
Christian has his people call si piece
IT people to have the email to lead it
off the servers and then Jack comes back
into the scene and just tells Anna
the situation has changed and management
says she's not allowed to go to New York
after all and Hannah goes to ask Allah
and then Alayna shows up and they argue
then Alayna leaves and Ana fights with
Christian about Elena and then they
fight about Ana not being allowed to
drive her new car and there's a whole
subplot where Kate's brother Ethan not
to be confused with Kate's boyfriend
Elliot is staying over for a few days so
Ana needs to get him the spare keys to
her apartment but Christian doesn't want
her to leave the office and gets mad at
her because she walked to the deli to
get lunch and so she needs to get
explicit permission from Christian to
walk out to the curb to hand Ethan the
house keys and all of that takes
multiple emails to negotiate
chapter 17 consists largely of Christian
allowing Ana to drive her new car for
the first time an event through which he
treats her like a tween being allowed to
pull down the driveway for the first
time and not you know an adult who's
been driving for years and is
comfortable making the three-hour drive
from Portland to Seattle and back like
he won't let her turn on the radio
because music would be too distracting
can we have the radio on I asked as we
wait at the first stop sign I want you
to concentrate
he says sharply Christian please I can
drive with music on I roll my eyes he
scowled for a minute then reaches for
the radio you can play your iPod and mp3
discs as well as CDs on this he murmurs
also that exchange implies he's
compromising by letting her listen to
her personal collection of music but not
the radio I mean I get that this is
supposed to be Christian obsessing over
Anna's safety like reviewing the
actuarial tables for the Saab 9-3
convertible option after Anna says maybe
should like to get a convertible is just
an extension of hiring more security
guards after Leela gets a gun permit but
it's also kinda dumb and yes that does
happen
Christian frowns and peers at me
convertible
he asks raising an eyebrow I flush it's
like he has a direct hotline to my inner
goddess which of course he has it's most
inconvenient at times I stare down at my
hands Christian turns to Troy what are
the safety stats
the convertible Troy sensing Christians
vulnerability heads in for the kill
reeling off all manner of statistics
it's not cute there is no tension and
it's not relevant
there's no moment where it builds to any
meaningful conflict or payoff it's
clearly supposed to be an extension of
Christians damage 52 [ __ ] up but how
does any of his trauma connect to
obsessing over safety it doesn't so in
the internal logic this is just a
personality trait that the character
developed all on his own is not
motivated by anything in particular it's
not an expression or extension of the
core conflict the character needs to
deal with it's just one more entirely
distinct personality flaw in a laundry
list of distinct unrelated personality
flaws oh and the other half of chapter
17 is Anna talking to Christians
therapist for 15 pages a conversation
that basically amounts to hey did you
know BDSM isn't a mental illness and
also you're totally fixing him doctor
Flynn sighs Anna in the very limited
time that you've known him you've made
more progress with my patient than I
have in the last two years you've had a
profound effect on him you must see that
they have been dating for three and a
half weeks by page count these kinds of
meaningless circular repetitive
arguments are the actual nature of 50
shades darker because this kind of
structure 'less mass is the stuff that
master of the universe is made of now
it's really easy to talk about
serialized literature as a kind of
de-facto negative like serialization is
going to yield garbage by default and it
takes an exceptional storyteller to
elevate it beyond the baseline but
that's not true well there are a lot of
tells that serial fiction tends to leave
behind when approached in a compiled or
completed form usually it just adds to
the flavor and texture of the work it
lends itself to being less tightly or
rigidly structured but serial isn't
synonymous with structureless and
unfocused the ability to stay phone
just to understand your characters and
themes to have a compelling plot or
scenario or world or whatever the hook
is for your story these are just basic
storytelling skills also I feel like
it's worth pointing out that master of
the universe and Fifty Shades by
inheritance isn't even really episodic
now despite their close relationship
episodic fiction and serial fiction
aren't synonymous to kill a mockingbird
is episodic but not serial while many
web comics like questionable content are
cereal but story lines are too long and
flowing to really be considered episodic
and just as a sidebar
I enjoy questionable content I think
it's charming slice of life drama but it
would make an awful movie if you tried
to adapt it as is instead of taking the
characters and premise and writing a
screenplay from scratch just sayin the
hallmark of episodic fiction is in the
name well-defined episodes with each
episode following an identifiable plot
structure as a micro version of the work
as a whole the enterprise has arrived at
a place where something is happening
things go wrong then they get worse then
someone comes up with a solution and the
credits roll this structure or indeed
any structure is entirely absent in
master of the universe chapters swing
wildly from 5 to 21 pages and these
chapters were then compressed together
during the conversion to novel which is
where you get weirdness like fifty
shades darker chapter 11 where in the
course of a single chapter the trip to
New York for book Expo is both
introduced and canceled this is why the
culminating moment of the first book
Anna
breaking up with Christian is completely
undone within the first 30 pages of the
second book in turn this is why the
start of the movie is so jumbled and
haphazard
and it's why the movie effectively ends
here with Christians big moment but
keeps going for another 45 minutes
afterwards darker isn't really the start
of a second major arc
it's just the ongoing stream of
consciousness compulsive writing of
someone more concerned with maintaining
their online status their presence and
dominance in a community than they are
with the actual story that they're
telling
once you approach master of the universe
and its derivatives as first and
foremost serial fiction as public
performance it all snaps into sharp
focus
suddenly you understand why there's a
helicopter crash that is effortlessly
resolved a few minutes later when
Christian just walks in the door why'd
the principal antagonist of the film the
stalker that was given a tremendous
amount of visual weight during the
introduction is dealt with off screen at
the midpoint of the film and never seen
again
the movie tries though half-heartedly
but it tries they flipped the conflict
with Jack and the conflict with Leela in
order to try and create some element of
escalation since you no gun but that's
about as extreme as it gets with
adaptation 'el there's still almost half
the movie hanging off the back end of
the climax and master of the universe
really is the original sin here since
that manuscript was never edited was
never properly condensed and reworked
into a focus story with plot threads
weaving in between each other everything
still arrives in a very serial order
well huge chunks of the book can be
discarded because they're just
meaningless arguments the plot itself is
a very rigid sort of chaos it's an
illusory transitive sequence like a b c
b c d c d e d e f e FG chapter 4 has
nothing to do with chapter 1 but you
can't remove it without making chapter 5
incomprehensible there's just enough
overlap between each one that it's
almost impossible to change anything
structural without getting completely
radical you can't just drop the back
half of the movie because that's where
the entire proposal story happens which
can't just be turfed because it's the
foundation of the third movie which is
being shot back-to-back with this one
and you can't weave that into the rest
of the movie because that entire
storyline is contingent on Christians
big emotional breakthrough moment and
that moment can't be pushed earlier
because it's the culmination of a
conflict with Leela which is actually
sort of the plot of the stuff proceed
so you can't just push that earlier
because then you just have the opposite
problem where there's a weird stalker
plot taking up the first half hour of
the movie and this isn't even touching
on the Jacke stuff which is almost
entirely superfluous to the story of
darker but can't be cut because it's the
core plot of the next movie baby it's
gonna take more than a malfunctioning
1:35 to keep me away from you
135 Charlie Tango she's a eurocopter
ec135 the safest in its class all right
let's work through these pins first up
you Oh No
what do you call it a vanilla
relationship I mean we only do what
you're comfortable with so vanilla as a
relationship term doesn't really have a
set meaning like people who are really
into BDSM and kink consider the stuff
that Christian and Anna do to be pretty
vanilla this is basically the joke that
I use to open the previous video in this
series YouTube law states that you can't
do a video about fifty Shades of Grey
without wearing fuzzy pink handcuffs or
some other non-threatening bachelorette
party level signifier of kink that
inadvertently captures the dissonance
between intensity of the marketing
around Fifty Shades of Grey
as some really taboo pushing kink and
the actual product but to a lot of
people the stuff that they do goes way
out of the realm of vanilla like wearing
a hidden sex toy to a very public high
society event that's actually kind of
hardcore but we're not here to litigate
the precise definition of vanilla I just
want to address it to contrast what
Christian actually says I mean we only
do what you're comfortable with yeah
it's super gross that the movie expects
us to think Christian is being totally
magnanimous by agreeing to respect her
limits
this actually becomes another indicator
of the changing creative teams
well darker Zanna still behaves and
holds herself more or less the same on a
deep level the movie just doesn't
understand Anna or care about what
she might want or think about something
Anna is simultaneously supposed to be
super weirded out by all the kinky stuff
and her own relationship to it but she's
also down for just about anything the
previous two times that Anna was spanked
by Christian it triggered a lot of
intense emotions but he or she just goes
with it asks for it because the author's
think it's hot the whole point of their
breakup which anna says out loud is that
she doesn't feel like she can trust him
because he gets off on hurting her i
want you back i don't see how you were
getting off on the pain you inflicted so
with that as the context a scene like
the one where christian brings out the
Benoit balls become suspect Christian
doesn't explain what they are he doesn't
try to build trust or confirm that she's
comfortable with the idea he takes her
comfort as implied because the author's
already know she's going to be okay with
it because they're making the damn thing
this trust me it's a surprise you'll
like it dynamic isn't bad or unhealthy
on its own but it's explicitly the
opposite of the dynamic the other half
of the movie says these characters have
this is a running motif throughout the
film where the author's use
non-communication
as the setup for sex play and in
Christian have an exchange about the
spreader bars that's comical for a
number of reasons to walk before we run
first it hits this point of non
communication where Christian just
refuses to actually explain anything
second he's already had Anna tied up
spread-eagled to his sex bed in his sex
dungeon in their own analogy a spreader
bar is maybe a light jog alright next
pin when you and I were in Georgia
together she turned up here and tried to
slit her wrists and for them mrs. Jones
my housekeeper this is a hilarious bit
of backfill since it amounts to here's a
super important thing that happened just
off camera left during the last movie
but we never mentioned it and this is
exactly how it's done in the books too
now I don't blame Kelly Marcie
for not mentioning it during Fifty
Shades of Grey it's completely
irrelevant to the story of the book that
she was adapting but it's equally
telling that Neil Leonard didn't think
of a better way to do it like I don't
know what if they're at Christians place
instead of Anna's and this intensely
boring sex scene was replaced with a
dark action scene where they're kissing
is interrupted by Leela walking in and
she grabs the knife that Christian was
using and the three of them had a
confrontation that sets the stakes for
shadows of the climax of the film and
actually happens on screen because it's
exciting and dramatic just saying also
since we're here we might as well talk
about this pin as well I really don't
see why we can't just go back to your
apartment that place is like a fortress
there's no way she could have gotten in
there she shouldn't have been able to
get into the garage either she already
broke into your apartment once before
now this isn't a plot hole it's a fairly
inconsequential line but it makes the
writers look lazy like they didn't
really know their own story you know
almost like they were just kind of
writing each scene one by one really
quickly without ever going back and
doing a second draft to tighten the
story up pin the third do you think
you're the first woman he'd hoped would
save him like its characters the movie
does a terrible job at defining its
boundaries the philosophical stance of
the villain Elena Lincoln is that
Christian is so damaged that he needs
his BDSM lifestyle in order to be
functional but is incapable of happiness
there's a few problems here problem the
first well this is the stance of the
villain it's never actually repudiated
by anyone or anything else no one ever
questions four basic premise that
Christians BDSM thing is emergent from
his trauma they simply disprove her
conclusion by having Anna fix Christians
problems problem the second the movie
does a really bad job at differentiating
bondage and other kinky play which
typically has some elements of power
dynamic inherent in one partner being
restrained and the other doing the
restraining from power dynamics of
submission and domination as a result
everyone
is constantly talking about this thing
that Christian needs but you need all
those things he needs a submissive in
life but it's what he needs maybe you
just really need someone who obeys every
command what's gonna happen when you
start needing them again but this
happens without clearly defining how
exactly this nebulous need is different
from all the kinky stuff that they do
get up to beyond the vague sense of more
and total control this is backing up to
the previous film but there's no clear
sense of what a day in the life of being
Christians sub would actually look like
like he says total submission but that
doesn't actually mean anything on its
own it's entirely subjective to the
whims and tastes of the dominant however
that's not to say that the question is
unanswered if you put in the legwork of
digging out all the parts and filling in
the blanks the answer is that he wants a
sex slave who doubles as a replacement
mother he selects subs who look like his
dead mom who he refers to throughout the
books as the crack [ __ ] the crack [ __ ]
my birth mother expects them to clean
and cook wants them to be sexually
available at all times and they just
have to let him beat them really really
really hard with a belter King and
that's actually about it he just wants
someone he can whip with a belt whenever
he's angry or frustrated or horny who
otherwise does whatever banal thing
springs into his head and generally
mothers him when they're not in sex mode
that's not intense kink so much is it's
the profile of a serial killer and okay
like I said in the previous installment
this admission that Christian is
actually really bad as a dominant that
he's actually a predator who uses the
role of dominant to find submissives who
almost universally piece out after they
realized they've been conned into
participating in his maternal revenge
fantasy that's not invalid as a dramatic
idea but it's not admitted or even
really acknowledged until the scene
where Christian is like that's who I was
but I'm fixed now see I'll let you touch
my scars and then functionally dropped
and this is because of problem the third
Erica Mitchell thinks that all power
exchange is equally immoral proposes
that engaging in submission and
domination relationships will damage you
to the point that you can only be cured
by true love and doesn't differentiate
between Christians narcissistic oedipal
psychopathy and other forms of power
exchange the two relevant scenes here
are Anna's conversation with Hannah and
the climactic encounter with Leela in
the first we get the most
philosophically coherent statement of
the film summed up just go with the flow
the correct way to have a relationship
is to just like figure it out man and
the rest of it will just make up as we
go which is not you know terrible advice
later as far as far as advice goes it's
fine in the second we get the supporting
argument being a submissive will melt
your brain
you can maybe understand why the BDSM
kinky community isn't exactly hot on
this property
pins five and six the complete non
argument argument about Book Expo and if
you really want to go then I can't stop
you but I'd like to take you there
myself okay so this is changed a bunch
from the book but it's still intensely
frustrating because it's just so so so
poorly written the change for the better
is that when Christian first tells Ana
no you can't go she responds with I
wasn't asking all right cool conflict
but then the substance of the argument
just gets bizarre so he keeps telling
her that if she wants to go to New York
he'll take her to New York because he
wants to be there the first time she
sees New York if you want to go to New
York don't go with Hyde let me take you
I have a place there and Ana points out
that it's not seeing New York it's a
business trip and yeah being stuck in
the Javits Center for a weekend isn't
exactly seeing the sights but Christian
just keeps repeating his offer to take
Anna to see New York he just completely
talks past her over and over until Danna
just takes this as a valid response and
drops the issue all of this as a
cumulative element of the movie makes
Ana into a much more passive agent than
she was under the previous writer and
director
well grey managed a nominal character
arc of Anna learning to stand up for her
boundaries no in this film Anna manages
at best some token resistance before
caving and acquiescing to whatever
Christian wants and now you may be
wondering why is this glorious non
argument argument even here okay so in
the book at this point Christian knows
that Jack Hyde is a rapist but he's not
telling Anna because he's trying to
prove to her that he's better than her
and that the world is too dangerous for
her to be anything other than his sub
but if we take out Christians meddling
entirely then it's going to be complete
insane when Jack turns into mr. Hyde and
tries to molest Anna in a couple days
and if we take that out then the entire
third movie is ruined ah baby it's gonna
take more than a malfunctioning 135 pin
number six
mrs. Jones's introduction oh my god Oh
scuse me I didn't mean to startle you
no no I you are you've very quiet
I'm mrs. Jones mr. Gray's housekeeper
this is the kind of awful filmmaking
that I'm here for this bit fails on
literally every level possible without
adding wind tunnel noises and a live
studio audience to the soundtrack I'm
mrs. Jones mr. Gray's housekeeper mrs.
Jones is Christian's housekeeper she's a
bit part introduced early in the books
but dropped from the first movie because
she's a bit part that's completely
irrelevant to the story and for
absolutely no discernible reason 30
minutes into the second movie she gets a
full introduction and is introduced like
a horror villain like seriously there's
an unsettling length of time in this
shot where the camera avoids showing her
face why was this cut like this why is
it shot like this in the first place why
does any of this even happen okay so not
only has Anna being at Gray's apartment
many many times often for days at a time
over the past month but mrs. Jones has
already been in this movie she's
mentioned in one scene and grey talks to
her over the phone in another she turned
up here and tried to slit her wrists so
for them mrs. Jones my housekeeper
yes in a minute Emma drill her presence
is already established it is 100% okay
if Anna walks in and goes hey mrs. Jones
like they've already met off screen it's
a trivial relationship that is exactly
as deep as it appears mrs. Jones is the
housekeeper end of story
but just to contextualize this creative
decision in the priority of things that
the movie feels are important to show us
Lila showing up and trying to kill
herself she turned up here and tried to
slit her wrists so for them mrs. Jones
my housekeeper Anna meeting the
housekeeper for the first time I'm mrs.
Jones mr. Gray's housekeeper all right
well we're talking about bit characters
let's talk about pin 8 can I just say
this is Gretchen Gretchen is a blonde
which in the logic of Fifty Shades means
that she's a temptress and homewrecker
Gretchen shows up a couple times in the
book to make Moony eyes at Christians so
that Ana can think to herself about how
much she hates Gretchen and hates that
other women think her hot boyfriend is
hot Gretchen serves no purpose since
literally every other similar moment
from the books up to this point has been
dropped from the films making this one
moment five minutes before the end of
the movie really really weird also can
we just talk for a moment about how
Christian the reclusive cold weirdo with
no social skills is constantly referred
to as the most eligible bachelor in
Seattle when his brother Elliot is one
better-looking too also extremely rich
and three a totally chill bro Playboy
serial dater who owns a construction
company and a chain of surf shops okay
pin seven I'm not a dominant I'm not the
right term is a sadist I get off in
punishing women women who look like you
mother so if you haven't caught on by
now this line is different from the way
it appears in the book and well part of
me is disappointed because the crack
[ __ ] my birth mother is such a
transcendentally awful phrase that
was really looking forward to watching a
human tried to act it out I'm not
particularly surprised that it was
changed this change almost certainly
came as a mandate from Universal a
reader for the studio had to go through
the books and make a bunch of notes for
necessary adaptation Elena's and top of
the page was you cannot use the phrase
the crack [ __ ] to refer to Christians
birth mother it may feel like I've
overused that clip but it's deliberate I
can't really adequately explain just how
repetitive and mean-spirited the books
are so this is the best way of
communicating that essence this line
right here is the soul of the Fifty
Shades books I'm a sadist I like to whip
little brown haired girls like you
because you all look like the crack
[ __ ] my birth mother
while we're on the subject one of the
horror movie aspects of this exchange
that the books tried to pass off as
romantic is the extrapolated logic the
Christian staffs his office exclusively
with blondes specifically because they
don't remind him of his dead mom and
thus he won't want to punish them and/or
have sex with them so the last big thing
that I want to talk about for this
installment is Jack let's talk about
Jack I wasn't entirely sure where to put
this because it's important here in
darker but it's only important here
because it's critical in freed so I
think I'll try to talk about it here and
we'll see if this makes any sense at all
Jack Hyde is the primary antagonist of
Fifty Shades freed he breaks into Grey's
office to firebomb their servers it's
backfilled that Christians helicopter
crash is due to Jack's sabotaging the
motor he attempts to kidnap Anna at
knifepoint then kidnaps Christian's
sister Mia and threatens to shoot her if
Anna doesn't give him five million
dollars in ransom all the other stuff
that's set up and floating around
unresolved at the end of fifty shades
darker stays that way Jose getting this
jealous close up at the engagement
announcement he has like one line in the
next film
Elena Lincoln she's not even in the
theatrical version of freed Lila the
stalker who attacked Anna with a gun is
mentioned once to assure
the audience that she's accounted for
and totally definitely not involved it
all in any way but it raises the
question did they not read the third
book before writing the second movie why
didn't they fix problems they knew about
if you know that this character is going
to become the central climactic villain
of your entire series why would you not
put in a bit more legwork to actually
build that up yes the answer is that
they're lazy hacks caching and easy
paycheck but why would you basically
advertise that fact shouldn't you at
least try to hide it they dropped the
ball on this so badly that the first
time I saw the film I wasn't really sure
who this was I originally read Frede
very quickly in a haze back in 2013 and
had largely forgotten pretty much the
entire book aside from the inexplicable
subplot where Ana stepdad gets into a
car accident that occupies a good chunk
of the back half of the book so the fact
that Jack Hyde was in fact going to be
the main antagonist wasn't at the
forefront of my brain and sitting
through the movie had sapped whatever
cognitive capacity was left so the movie
finally gets to the end and there's this
sinister character in the dark looking
all beat up
and it's a dude who disappeared from the
movie almost entirely an hour earlier
and I honestly said to myself wait who
is that I know I said earlier that it
was a good choice to swap the Jack and
Leela confrontations but it's yet
another good microcosm of the catch-22
that is adapting these books the
confrontation with Leela is the more
dramatic one Leela is in the middle of a
complete meltdown and she has a gun the
stakes are higher the jeopardy is higher
and the confrontation itself ties into
the relationship between gray and Hanna
in a more coherent and direct manner of
the two attacks it is the appropriate
climax of this movie but it's not
important to the series as a whole it's
almost worse that they actually did add
in a bunch of changes to try and draw
explicit parallels between Christian and
Jack like Jack is supposed to be the
evil version of Christian which fails as
a parallel because Christian is already
the evil version of Christian and that
they inserted him at the ball
taking the photo of Christians family
because it shows some level of awareness
of the problem but then addressed in the
laziest lowest effort manner possible
the fact that Christians helicopter was
sabotage by Jack is still going to come
up in the next movie but nothing was
added to this one to make that any more
plausible as a plot point in fact this
movie actually does less than the books
to suggest that it was foul play baby
it's gonna take more than a
malfunctioning 135 to keep me away from
you Charlie Tango
she's a eurocopter ec135 the safest in
its class and for our purposes that's
going to be our bridge to Fifty Shades
freed join me next time for a grotesque
overly long video that's basically one
giant third act devoid of its own
internal structure just like the book
that it's based on
[Music]
you